yo first up today the unthinkable has
happened dave chappelle got cancelled oh
he's being sarcastic right
yeah yes okay yeah yeah yeah shut up
phil defranco i know i know we had
an issue with him in the past but i
actually think he does a half decent job
i think he does a previous job what is
that because you have an issue with
someone that you can't call over
something they said yeah yeah it's okay
that's fine but i could i could have an
issue with someone and be like yeah
that you'd be [ __ ] up but if we focus
something they do you also gotta say
shadow yeah no problem like whenever i
say some [ __ ] up [ __ ] you call me out
all the time when you say some [ __ ]
[ __ ] i'll call you all the time you're
not canceling nobody no not that one
yeah but like not in the social media
way but like actually in real life so
yesterday he was scheduled to perform at
the first avenue theater in minneapolis
if you don't know it's a significant
theater dave has performed there before
it's also in prince's purple rain film
many believe that it should be declared
a historical landmark but just hours
before chappelle was supposed to take
the stage the theater cancelled his gig
at the venue and said it would be
switching it to a new location no they
did not explicitly say why it appears to
have to do with the backlash and
criticism the comedian has faced over
transphobic remarks with first avenue
saying in a statement to staff artists
and our community we hear you and we are
sorry we know we must hold ourselves to
the highest standards and we know we let
you down we are not just a black box
with people in it and we understand that
first avenue is not just a room but
meaningful beyond our walls and adding
that the theater and its supporters have
worked hard to make the venue a safe
space continuing we believe in diverse
voices in the freedom of artistic
expression but in honoring that we lost
sight of the impact this would have we
know there are some who will not agree
with this decision you are welcome to
send feedback
is it just me or don't all these
apologies always sound the same yeah
because an apology apology sounds the
same but not not now it's a business
apology so it's even worse it's based on
a model that works but and the thing
that happened is that whenever you do an
apology even if you're
if you
are sincere in your apology and your
business
it's just going to sound the same as
someone that's not
sincere i think the issue i have is that
they say i'm sorry like we should have
been more considerate your feelings you
know we let you guys down we'll do
better next time
but they never really condemn the stuff
or say like he's actually wrong and he
is absolutely trans they don't never go
hard on that so when i'm watching this
i'm like okay if you feel the super
apprehensive say it's reprehensible say
you actually think it's wrong you don't
say that you're just like i know you're
hurt i don't mind if
a business takes a strong stance in
regards to saying i'm pro
this and i feel like this is condemning
or if chick-fil-a says we're not for uh
same-sex marriage and we don't open on
sundays to church i don't i'm not mad at
that
what i what i find like really slimy is
how they
take a strong stance through their
actions no cause you got to let the door
open
you got to let the door open you got to
say you apologize but you got to because
you things can unfold because that's
right so
i got to say i'm sorry your feeling got
hurt
i didn't say i'm sorry i hurt you i'm
sorry you're feeling god hurts and well
yeah all right
and then you don't condemn that so if
ever a change of thing happened
oh yeah yeah you can always come back
yeah but you can't throw a show oh it's
just yeah the backlash we never said you
was wrong door open
you could come back in the future yeah
you can come back the door is open
when there's not that much heat yeah
when the heat comes down you can come
back in the winter you understand you
know that
yeah but that's what it is so yeah no
you're i understand what you're saying
but you don't that's not the point of an
apology of especially a business apology
trash and then telling ticket holders
they would get an email about their
tickets being transferred to the new
location varsity theater with varsity
theater then confirming and following up
by letting fans know that their tickets
would be honored at its doors and
notably varsity had already scheduled to
host chappelle today and friday so it
was the logical switch as the venue had
already given him the green light as
you'd expect this has prompted a ton of
conversation and questions online about
why first avenue chose to ditch the
event so suddenly some claiming that the
staff at first avenue called out in
protest so there were actually no
workers to work the gig though notably
no official reports yet have confirmed
and mentioned that others have pointed
to a change.org petition that said dave
has a record of being dangerous to trans
people and first avenue has a duty to
protect the community that petition only
had around 126 signatures so it wasn't
big but clearly in some capacity whether
it be from staff or supporters the venue
was facing backlash big enough for a
last-minute cancellation so now with
these two venues doing two drastically
different things both are receiving heat
online some accusing first avenue of
embracing cancel culture saying they're
hypocrites picking and choosing what
voices they support but on the other
side you have people upset and pointing
the finger at varsity saying they're
platforming transphobia with a star
tribune even reporting that a few dozen
protesters went to the theater before
the show chanting trans lives matter and
so far as a recording chappelle has not
released a statement about the situation
but my thinking well he may have
feelings to a certain degree about that
venue i'm not sure i have to imagine in
general he's fine with this
shout out to first avenue
helping dave chappelle sell out a whole
bunch of tickets free publicity but
that's what happened to our man uh
andrew schultz free custody that's what
happens free publicity every time one of
these people cancel the venue and say we
don't endorse your speech everyone hears
that their ears perk up like who's this
oh they must be saying something
important if you didn't want to let him
through the front door can we get
tickets to the back door pause
come on
run us a chicken i want to see what
yours you're not allowed to see on the
main stage huh
i've had a few drinks but what did that
boy show say but i can't but i'll say
stick it to the abortion clinics let's
go but keep the back door open please i
can answer yeah
i like the way i like the way this is
going you know what i'm gonna start
trying to see if i can sign up to some
like you know
questionably political affiliated uh
venues get really hype about the whole
thing and then have them cancel on me
make a lot of money you know
how you're taping this yeah you're
taping you're taping this
you see you see what happened you're
taping this you're gonna release this
and then some [ __ ] like that's going to
happen and people are going to be like
it was all planned yeah and they even
did and they still going to buy tickets
in fact you know what i want to do i
know some [ __ ] who run some venues
i know some [ __ ] who wrestle venues we
gonna book they go okay so cause i'm
about to slip the money under the table
and then everybody get a cut let's get
some of that canceled cultural money you
know what i'm saying that profitation
huh that's ecm yes it's called cancer
culture money hey let's talk about that
that's crazy i want some of that cheddar
you think dave is mad about this he just
saw his ticket sale it's like it's like
it's like it's like when chris rock got
slapped his bank account also got
slapped you feel me stop with a big
check
speaking of chris rock you know he
didn't write that joke he what he didn't
write that joke smack you know the
comedian who wrote that joke in the back
like that joke does slap
you know he felt good oh yeah
yeah my joke my joke gets the people out
these listen we not the same
we not the same
your joes get claps
mojo gets slapped
onto the actual topic yeah
hey i don't know what's like you call me
up he called me up to to cover this
what do you got to say about this
because obviously you got some [ __ ] to
say not really
yeah you called me i called you because
it's a hot topic it is a hot topic but
what you got to say about this i mean
let's get this money
you know at first i was like getting
annoyed by these people now every time
they speak up i'm just like man
everybody's so tired of y'all shut the
[ __ ] up
and if you want to keep talking keep
talking we're gonna make some more money
that's how i feel about it so you guys
do all this faux outrage it's all like
oh my god there's no danger nobody
believes you anymore and that's why all
artists see themselves shoot up the
ranks when they say the [ __ ] that they
say even mainstream media all these
companies are starting to not follow
suit take
um
netflix
with the whole dave shout out they said
you don't like it [ __ ] leave because we
trying to make money you you don't have
to you don't have to be
you don't have no to choose this
platform there's other platforms
joe rogan when everybody was saying all
that [ __ ] about him dude grew by like i
think was like 200 million or something
like that what do you mean no he grew by
two million subscribers yes
so there was an influx of new fans who
were showing support and his numbers
went up and a lot of people who said
they were gonna boycott spotify ended up
resigning up a few months later after
everything quiet down so that whole
little boycott that they try to organize
keep the back door open yeah come back
when they first come yeah we hate to see
you leave but come back whenever the
small calm yeah you know what that was
like what was i like [ __ ] if you don't
change your waist i'ma leave
door's open no i'm really gonna do it
door's open
you're gonna miss me
door's open
you're gonna miss me
india
is here he's on spotify
oh my god
oh
my
god i feel like they were like bro
and they just pop right back
so did you miss me
no you didn't ask me oh my god babe
please let me back in i missed you come
on baby everything's on there of course
everything's popular really oh my god
come on bro these people are not serious
you want to know the united states
because they don't actually follow
through with their convictions i'm
leaving they don't die but they're not
willing to to really go to bat for what
they believe in they just virtue
signaling so it's it's very difficult
when your virgin signaling doesn't work
and you got to lose some cheddar all of
a sudden you start bending over and you
just where do you want me to take it up
the booty oh my god but again oh that
problematic dick yeah girl you gonna
take it
you gonna take it i probably about it
yeah you're gonna take it why cause that
should come with some money you're gonna
take it crazy so all this yipping
yapping about i will not tolerate
systems of oppression oh sir is that
that capitalism penis yes please
that's crazy shut the [ __ ] up that's
crazy what the [ __ ] up i was i was just
running a test that's crazy so maybe
it's not her that put her songs there if
it's not you indeed or someone looking
like you uh posting your music on social
media what you got what you got
what on this topic um
i'm sick of hearing about it he canceled
for what what did i do you went to
another venue that's it most of you
[ __ ] are not even you don't
even watch this comedy and that's it i
understand is the message is the message
well maybe you're missing the message
maybe you're missing the whole thing all
these people that are against that while
trans lives matter yes
it does
and he didn't say nothing against that i
mean
didn't say nothing against that
you disagree maybe you feel like he is
problematic we disagree other people
disagree it is what it is but when you
tell people you can't have matters venue
because we think he's saying well just
like we don't buy and we're not gonna
listen to you and we're not gonna cow
tail just because you claim so so until
you make more compelling arguments
nobody really going to jump on board so
that's my thoughts on the whole thing
anything else
guess who's back
[Music]
get this money baby that's funny